humankind is not woven the web of life
we are but one thread within it whatever
we do to the web we do to ourselves all
things are bound together all things
connect
the diversity of life on Earth is
entirely dependent on one crucial
element water from glaciers to rivers to
the oceans over 70% of the planet is
covered with water 97% of that is
saltwater the health of our planet lies
in the health of our oceans our
increasing population and growing
dependency on disposable products is
rapidly polluting the oceans science is
revealing the devastating impacts of
plastics as there is now more plastic
than plankton biomass in our oceans
in our world's oceans we have five major
gyres these are big large circulating
bodies of water where you're in the in
the larger Atlantic gyre that referred
to as the Sargasso Sea what happens is
with this gyre because it's circulating
everything seems to coagulate in the
center so just as everybody's heard
about this big plastic mat that's in the
Pacific they've actually found one
that's actually in the Atlantic that's
just as big if not bigger things like
plastic and particular buoyant so they
can sit on the surface and the winds and
currents will will move them around and
and we look at the bigger issues of have
all this materials been accumulating in
our oceans for four decades really
massive plastic guys have been
documented in every major ocean 80% of
marine debris comes from the land by
storm drains rivers and legal and
illegal dumping once it enters the ocean
it is carried by currents out into the
Gaia's where it is held out about view
Bermuda is unique in the fact that it's
the in the middle of the trash tire in
the middle of the Sargasso Sea
the Sargasso Sea is named after floating
algae called Sargassum the Sargassum
collects in large mats on the surface
creating a unique and safe nursery for
over 150 species many are endemic to the
Sargasso Sea this community is being
heavily impacted by plastic pollution
the Sargassum community is one link in
this massive chain so if the Sargassum
community is not healthy and fails the
ripples of that will actually affect
seabirds sea turtles whales everything
we think of in the ocean sigh gaseous
sea itself is actually super important
when you consider one of the big carbon
sinkholes on the planet the the filter
so to speak the reviving of the
chemicals that we're burning up it
produces one in every fifth breath we
breathe so if we lose the Sargasso Sea
if it crumbles because of pollution
overfishing or whatever I think it'd be
just absolutely tragic for the whole
planet
we get a lot of ocean debris especially
during storm surges and and gales
hurricanes where it will push a lot of
debris onto Bermudas beaches what
happens to this materials it gets broken
into smaller and smaller pieces through
soar the action of sunlight no degrade
in the plastic so it makes it brittle
then you have wave and wind action which
will take this fasik and break it into
pieces and then animals such as fishes
that begin to chew on this plastic
material again breaking it into smaller
pieces and so that sort of disappears by
becoming smaller and smaller so it's
less visible to us when we're actually
on the ocean one of the most abundant
types of micro plastics in the ocean is
noodles noodles are small pellets that
are the precursors of all plastic
products single-use and disposable
plastic products make up a large portion
of marine debris one of the big issues
with plastics is that it's creating
hazard for our animals and Wildlife and
marine life we see evidence clear
evidence that birds fish and turtles are
biting the plastic they're eating this
and mistaking it for their real food
when their stomach is full of plastic it
doesn't go through their digestive
system we've had Turtles here wash up
juvenile turtles did a full of plastic
could have died because they've just
consumed so much plastic thinking is
jellyfish plastically breaks down to a
certain size so what happens is once it
gets down so that's the smaller size it
doesn't any smaller that it doesn't
break down so all the filter feeders all
the small fish and things like that that
are filter feeding the plankton and
stuff I'm mistaking the bits of plastic
for
food chemicals pesticides and herbicides
runoff from land and adhere to floating
marine debris increasing toxicity to
marine life and ultimately to humans so
now these particles that can be mistaken
for food are not just a mechanical
problem for efficacy we're trying to
digest something they can't but it's
also laden with some of these chemicals
and if it gets into the digestive system
the digestive juices that break down
food will actually work to take some of
those chemicals off those plastic
particles and they'll enter the
digestive system into the circulatory
system of a sea bird or fish so it's
getting problem of something they can't
digest and it's getting chemicals that
are probably deleterious to it if that
animal is still alive after doing all
this and something else comes along to
eat that animal now that material that's
in that fish is going to move up the
food chain into whatever ate that so
that's a the issue of bioaccumulation
bioaccumulation
is the process of small fish getting
eaten by larger fish resulting in toxic
chemicals intensifying as they move up
the food chain the fish is then consumed
by humans and poses a growing threat to
our health people often think that
because something's in a plastic
container or a plastic water bottle it's
actually healthier but there's a lot of
research that says the chemicals in the
plastic will actually leach into the
food will leach into the water if you
test people's blood you will find
chemicals from plastics in their blood
and some of the chemicals are endocrine
disruptors which have a significant
impact on the hormone system they can
cause obesity they cause sex changes in
fish we don't really know how big the
problem is because we're not there when
that poor little turtle took its last
bite of a fatal piece of plastic and
killed it in the die we weren't there to
see that so we don't really know what
the magnitude of the impact is we just
know for sure that this stuff's out
there and they're eating it
at this point houses humans on the
planet we're all going to take
responsibility for the fact that
everything we buy comes triple wraps
twice covered in plastic and it's gonna
be us that changes how these companies
actually market their stuff if we as
individuals stand up and say well I
don't want to buy that because it's got
two layers of plastic on it we will set
the tone the awareness of actually
reducing the waste reducing what you use
in the first place
is so important because it's all very
well to dispose of it responsibly but
it's still a waste if it's not something
that we needed plastic bags for example
you ship in they've already come all
across the world and we use them for 10
or 15 minutes and so when we talk to
people we tell them that recycling is
not a solution here because everything
already has a big footprint so we focus
on reducing resource use reducing trash
reducing electricity
the use of plastics and our dependency
on plastics is probably one of the
biggest injustice is that we've done to
ourselves but then also to the planet is
if you continue to do what you've always
done you always get what you've always
gotten and we're not making it any
better for ourselves so we need to make
it better we need to stop being so
dependent on plastics
the fight against single-use plastics is
a global battle
the change is happening bans against
single-use plastics are occurring in
major cities encourage your local
restaurants grocery stores and community
to use alternatives reusable bags water
bottles to-go containers silverware and
compostable packaging are simple ways to
eliminate plastic from your life
humanity is facing an unprecedented
global challenge the removal of plastics
from our oceans will be extremely
difficult and it's magnitude lies hidden
just below the ocean's surface
we are one human family and the issue of
pollution is affecting all of us
the greatest threat to our planet is the
belief that someone else will save it
every day we have a choice make the
choice to refuse single-use plastics
you